hey it's me through the book I'm so
excited to watch my first appearing on
Conan with you let's hit play are there
any fun German traditions you can tell
us about that I might like to go to
Germany somebody I do travel my show
occasionally and maybe I would like to
get some business this is called a nice
easy said so I can spike it hard with
German details please I will be your
Tenzing Norgay you may be my Edmund
Hillary
we will walk around and have raisins and
peanuts those are two men that traveled
a lot they did not look like me or like
Conan and I don't think they died as
they walked so that's why I said it
let's continue please please freeze that
and google it that's fantastic that's
fantastic I would love to do that what
do you will so what would we do we would
we would what kind of things do we do
what do Germans do for fun we were to
wake it very the real answer is nothing
but I had to take comment something so
that he thinks maybe I should go whistle
I tricked him in the morning have the
birds trip or the birds or the worms out
no we have beaten the worms they are
still snoozing away Conan and we are
running around and we go to
oh it's the early bird the word early
bird catches the worm where's this
moment I thought I was going to be
removed from the show and deported so
I'm surprised it continued well the worm
isn't sleeping - we don't know what do
mean we don't know it's the worm lazy is
it - self-motivated worm we don't what
is the specie of worm - awesome slovenly
worms okay it's just it's so early that
the worms have been eaten yes got enough
I get it yeah yeah yeah yeah oh so so
punctual and he has a German last name
and so I knew he would be on my side to
help me out side note I flamed in this
funny park and have filled it with Jolly
Ranchers so what happens when we get up
really early what are we doing we wake
it up we eat some muesli immediately we
put some yogurt in the heights muesli
yogurt okay oh it is a delicious
combination it's like peanut butter and
peanut buddy and you know like a jello
delicious then we go for a hike it's
called a folk smart which means people's
March a people's votes mark oh yeah and
we walk for 10 kilometers exactly or 20
but we go time because and every 2.5
kilometres there is an old man in a tiny
boy and a dog on the bench and they give
you a stamp to make sure you have a
little boy why can't this be the old man
the boys excited to see you so you
rougher there here's a boy
oh I see the old man has cold cold t's
for you and the dog is smoking all of
the trips that you have done is you are
drinking it I owe everything has it
every single ice
so many after all everything lips except
for it's just getting this way fine what
can you get with the stamp when you turn
the stamp in what do you get after the
for stamps you receive a plaque a trophy
or a large piece of cake Oh what I do
not know my conan is giggling but I am
happy he is not raging at me damn we
gotta go what I wish I would very much
like to go to Germany maybe I could come
to Germany with you I will join you and
you will join me we would be like a
three-legged sack race but with no sack
and it's not a race we will take our
time I once observed children playing
this game and so that's what they did
great what a wonderful time and
flashback it feels like yesterday but
more accurately it was 2.5 years ago
bye bye everyone see you want to exit
now so